I  by jingo we're at war again as everyone  knows live lap con splendid foreign  policy has made Britain love the whole  world over from Iraq to Afghanistan via  those funny little fellas in the Balkans  people have been dying for our democracy  for decades and of course it's all in a  good cause that's right freedom every  day thousands of foreign Johnny's a  jolly good show for liberating their  countries from stability and unsightly  high-rise buildings I always want you to  lick open-plan think me lip lip calm but  then why we never overstep the mark and  if we do we simply hold an inquiry and  while Britain schools and hospitals get  all the funding they need we still have  money to burn new plaque we're dropping  million pound bombs aren't you yes or  much rather pop artists can fade my  children so put your trust in us we come  in peace and you end up in pieces  you